he's done a fantastic job he's a friend
of everybody in the administration and I
got a call this morning early from Alex
and I think he did a very good job
yesterday under a lot of pressure he did
a fantastic job and he explained it he
made a deal that people are happy with
and then twelve years later they're not
happy with it you'll have to figure all
of that out but the fact is he has been
a fantastic Secretary of Labor and Alex
called me this morning and he wanted to
see me and I actually said well we have
to press right out here so perhaps you
just want to say it to the press but I
just want to let you know this was him
not me because I'm with them he was a
he's a tremendous talent he's a Hispanic
man he went to Harvard a great student
and in so many ways I just hate what
he's saying now because we're gonna miss
him but please Ellen Thank You mr.
president
over the last week I've seen a lot of
coverage of the Department of Labor and
what I have not seen his incredible job
creation that we've seen in this economy
more than five million jobs I haven't
seen that workplace injuries are down
bucking it through your trend workplace
fatalities are down [ __ ] a nuclear
trends that we've had the safest year
ever in mining the lowest summer
fatalities ever in mining I have seen
parts of this case that is over twelve
years old that has input and bedding at
multiple levels of Department of Justice
and as I look forward I do not think it
is right and fair for this
administration labor department to have
Epstein as the focus rather than the
incredible economy that we have
and so I called the president this
morning I told him that I thought the
right thing was to step aside no cabinet
positions are temporary trust it would
be selfish for me to stay in this
position and continue talking about a
case of 12 years old rather than about
the amazing economy we have right now
and so I submitted my resignation to the
president effective 7 days from today
effective one week from today earlier
this morning
there is no need at all as far as I'm
concerned I would have I watched Alex
yesterday I thought Alex did a great job
and you know you can always second-guess
people and you could say it should have
been tougher they do it with me all the
time I make a great deal with anybody
and then they say like the Democrats oh
it could have been better I got one
point two billion dollar settlement fine
from a company from ZTE and the next day
and everybody couldn't believe it the
next day the Democrat said oh he should
have got more so you can always be
second-guessed that's what people do I
just want to tell you this is a person
that I've gotten to know that hasn't
been an ounce of controversy at the
Department of Labor until this came up
and he's doing this not for himself he's
doing this for the administration and
Alex I think you'll agree I said you
don't have to do this he doesn't have to
do I do and we have we have as everybody
does we have Pat pizzelle a-- who right
now is a deputy and he'll be acting for
a period of time I think you know Pat
he's a good man highly recommended by
Alex but Pat is going to be acting and
we've already informed
yes and I did have a falling out a long
time ago the reason doesn't make any
difference frankly but I haven't spoken
to him in probably 15 years or more I
wasn't a big fan of Jeffry embassy that
I can tell you and now if you look the
remnants hurt this man and I hate to see
it happen I will say this and I say it
again and I say it loud and clear
Alex Acosta was a great Secretary of
Labor what he's done with plans and you
see the plans coming one after another
you're just about done with the 401k and
that that happened things that nobody
would even think of so it's very sad but
at the same time he wants to focus to be
an accomplishments not on what get
Duggan
[Music]
well Alex believe that I'm willing to
live with anything John I think you know
me I've lived through things that that
you wouldn't believe Alex felt that way
and he also felt we're so good we're
doing so well the economy the stock
market just hit the highest point
yesterday in the history of our country
our unemployment numbers are the best
they've ever been if you look at
specifically certain groups
african-american Asian Hispanic the best
unemployment numbers in the history of
our country you know there's so many
good things that he didn't want to
distract from that and I understand that
a hundred percent
go watch the pole
so Paul Ryan was not a talent he wasn't
a leader when the people in freedom and
great congressmen wanted to go after the
Dems for things that they did very badly
he wouldn't give subpoena
whereas Nancy claws he hands them out
like they're cookies Paul Ryan was a
lame duck for a long time as Speaker he
was unable to raise money he lost
control of the house the only success
Paul Ryan had was the time that he was
with me because we got taxes cut
I got regulation cuts I did that mostly
without him but for Paul Ryan to be
complaining is pretty amazing I remember
a day in Wisconsin a state that I won
where I stood up and made a speech and
then I introduced him and they booed him
off the stage ten thousand people so for
him to be going out and opening his
mouth is pretty incredible but maybe he
gets paid for that who knows maybe he
gets
[Applause]
so people come into our country
illegally we're taking them out legally
very simple it's not something I like
doing but people have come into our
country illegally we're focused on
criminal we're focused on if you look at
ms-13 but when people come into our
country we take those people out and we
take them out very legally they all have
papers and it's a process and I have an
obligation to do it they came in
illegally they go out legally what the
Democrats should be doing now is they
should be changing the loopholes they
should be changing asylum I've been
talking to that to you about this for a
long time they should be changing Asylum
there's so many things now let me let me
give you the good news
Mexico has done an outstanding job so
far
if you look at the border it's down now
30% and that's only one week inclusive
where they've got it together the
junipers just came out it's down it
looks like it's gonna end up being a
little bit about 30% down it's going to
be down more and more they have 21,000
and I say 21,000 Mexican soldiers on the
borders both their southern border and
our southern border
and we really have it in control the
problem is we have a big problem the
laws are so bad that Democrats have to
help us fix the immigration laws but
even with that because of the job that
Mexico is doing and yes they maybe did
it because of tariffs but they're doing
a great job that I appreciate
[Music]
no no whoo [ __ ] who said that
look anything you do the Democrats will
say it's not good in the meantime they
had a disaster they have these laws that
are so bad catch and release and you
look at the different laws Visa Lottery
that was the Chuck Schumer law it's a
disaster a lottery you pick them out a
lottery the Democrats have caused
tremendous problem what they've let
China get away with but years and years
China's been ripping this off they're
not ripping us off any more right now
companies - fleeing China because of the
tariffs and right now would take it in
billions of dollars and by the way our
people are not paying for it they're
paying for it they're paying for it by
depressing their currency and they're
putting a lot of money look nobody's
ever done what I've done with China and
that's fine and we'll get along with
China but you know when I see a guy like
Biden who's weak and ineffective and
everybody that knows him knows he's a
weak man he's an ineffective man
president she laughs at guys like that
now with that being said I would say
this president she who - all of these
guys go to bed at night and they pray
that Joe Biden or somebody like him
becomes president so they can continue
to rip off our country
[Music]
no I had no idea I had no idea I haven't
spoken to him in many many years but I
did have no other
I've already I've already talked about
the epson matter I gave a press
conference that according to the media
was longer than any other cabinet
official and dis administration you know
I will reiterate what I said previously
my point here today is we have an
amazing economy we have unemployment
lower than we have seen literally in my
lifetime and the focus needs to be on
this economy and on job creation on a
decrease fatalities in the workplace and
in mining and going forward that's where
this administration needs to focus not
on this matter
we are looking into it the platforms are
absolutely in my opinion 100% crooked
they discriminate against Republicans
and conservatives there are a hundred
percent dishonest that's my opinion and
something's going to be done but I can
tell you from personal experience I see
it I had something happened this morning
I won't tell you about it yet but these
platforms are 100 percent they're 100
percent
I was not a fan of Jeffrey Epstein and
you watched people yesterday saying that
I threw him out of a club I didn't want
anything to do with him that was many
many years ago it shows you one thing
that I have good taste
okay now other people they went all over
with them they went to his Island they
went all over the place he was very well
known in Palm Beach his Island whatever
this island was wherever it is I was
never there find out the people that
went to the island but Jeffrey Epstein
was not somebody that I respected I drew
him out in fact I think the great James
Patterson who's a member of mar-a-lago
made this statement yesterday that many
years ago I threw him out I'm not a fan
of Jeffrey Epstein you know what you
know what they came in illegally they
have to go out we have millions of
people standing on line waiting to
become citizens of this country they've
taken tests they've studied they've
learned English they've done so much
it's they've been waiting seven eight
nine years we have some waiting 10 years
to come in it's not fair that somebody
walks across the line and now they've
become
well I wish the British ambassador well
some people just told me a two-bed but
they said he actually said very good
things about me instead of referring to
other people and I guess I quoted
Lindsey Graham today he said some things
that were pretty nice too from the
British ambassador but look I wish the
British ambassador well but they've got
to stop their leaking problems they're
just like they have to stop them in our
country
we're not giving warning now we're not
giving there's nothing to be secret
about can I tell you what there's
nothing to be secret about Isis law
enforcement they're great Patriots they
have a tough job nothing to be secret
about if the word gets out it gets out
because hundreds of people know about
it's a major operation so the word gets
out it gets out it starts on Sunday and
they're going to take people out and
they're going to bring them back to
their countries or they're going to take
criminals out put them in prison or put
them in prison in the countries they
came from we're focused on criminals as
much as we can how many four we do
anything else
for instance ms-13
very important with taking them out by
the thousands we've already been taken
oh we didn't stop this we've been taking
criminals out for the last year these
people have been here for many years
ms-13 we're taking them out by the
thousands
we'll get a good
I think we'll have it in the end where
it'll be actually more accurate than a
census because we have information
gotten through other means whether you
look at social security or other places
we have including loan applications we
have information that's probably more
accurate than the information we could
get by going in and asking somebody are
you a citizen a lot of people aren't
going to tell the truth no no not only
didn't I back down I backed up because
anybody else would have given this up a
long time ago
the problem is we had three very
unfriendly courts they were judges that
weren't exactly in love with this whole
thing and they were wrong but it would
have taken a long time to get through
those courts you understand that better
than anybody John would it take it a
long time back up to the Supreme Court
so I ask is there another way and
somebody said there's a way that might
be better it might be more accurate they
explained that I said then what are we
wasting time we're going to be in court
for the next two years what are we
wasting time for in the meantime we have
to by law have the printing done so the
printing is started and we're already
finding out who the citizens are and who
they're not and I think more accurately
so what I heard this I said I think
that's actually better I think what
we're doing is actually better and only
the fake news which there's plenty
he's the great professionals these are
people that have done this for a long
time we're really looking for criminals
as much as we can we're trying to find
the criminal population which has been
coming into this country over the last
ten years we know who they are - we've
been taking them out by the thousands
specifically gang members from ms-13 and
other gangs we've been taking them out
by the thousands so so we are really
specifically looking for bad players but
we're also looking for people that came
into our country not through a process
they just walked over a line they have
to live don't know the mayors and
sanctuary cities like a mayor like de
Blasio is probably the worst fare in the
country from New York I don't even know
what his attitude is nobody does because
he doesn't work very hard nobody knows
what the hell he does but a guy like de
Blasio probably wouldn't want the raid
but many mayor's do most fairs do you
know why they don't want to have crimes
in their cities or stay
so nobody has treated the military
better than president Trump nobody
nobody's even come close and you see
that with budgets you see that with the
pay increases and you see that with
medical but you know what you see it
more than any place is with the vet
because the vets now have choice they
never had choice before before t wait
wait wait for 44 years
wait wait for 44 years we are looking at
that for 44 years they've tried to get
veterans choice I got it
nobody else could've got
okay
say it
well I think how many bites at the Apple
do you get we've gone through 500
witnesses 2,500 subpoenas I've let them
interview my lawyers I've let them mint
because I had nothing to do with Russian
now that's come out there was no
collusion but how many how many people
and how many times and this has been
going on for two and a half years rush
limbaugh said there's nobody else in the
world that he knows that could have
taken it and on top of taking it I've
been a great president I've done more
listen listen I've done more in two and
a half years than any other president
nobody's even close including we just
said veterans choice and all of the
other things I've got but for two and a
half years so now they have Molly go
make a speech that goes now they wanted
to have them again they want to go it
again and again and again because they
want to hurt the president for the
election because I see what I'm running
against you got sleepy Joe Biden he
doesn't have the energy to be President
and the people that are nipping on his
heels they don't have what it takes and
I can tell you that China and Russia and
I've been rougher on Russia than any
president in the last 50 years China and
Russia and try North Korea where I have
a relationship you don't have a man
testing nuclear anymore you have a man
wait wait you have a man that was so
happy to see me that's a good thing that
a bad thing you have a man that doesn't
smile a lot but when he saw me he smiled
he was happy you have a man that when I
came into office all he was doing before
under Obama was testing nuclear weapons
and blowing up mountains and now he's
not doing it
there's nothing he can't say he's
written a report the report said no
collusion and it said effectively no
obstruction because there's no
obstruction and the other thing is very
interesting so they find out there's no
collusion the whole thing is about
collusion so they find out it's no
collusion
now actually it was different it was bad
crimes committed by the other side we'll
find out about that I'm sure that's
being looked at right now so so there's
no collusion and there's no obstruction
now we have a great Attorney General now
he's strong and he's smart and he read
it and he studied it along with rod
Rosen Stein who worked it from the
beginning and rod Rhodes and Stein and
bill Barr said there's no obstruction
it's also interesting number one there's
no crime and how do you obstruct when
there's no crime also take a look at one
other thing it's a thing called article
2 nobody ever mentions article 2 it
gives me all of these rights and a level
that nobody has ever seen before we
don't even talk about article 2 so they
rule no collusion no obstruction very
simple
and you can only by the way you can only
get so many bites at the Apple we got to
get on to running a country
you got immigration infrastructure drug
prices the Democrats aren't working all
they're doing is trying to hurt people
like Alex Acosta a man who has done a
man who I have no idea
are you a Democrat no I have no idea you
know what I know you know what I know
about Alex he was a great student at
Harvard he's Hispanic which I which I so
admire because maybe it was a little
tougher for him and maybe not but he did
an unbelievable job as the Secretary of
Labor that's what I know about him I
know one thing he did a great job and
until this came up there was never an
ounce of problem with this very good man
and let me think let me just add let let
me let me let me let me just add you
know I hear a lot about how individuals
got jobs and whatnot before our
interview we had never met we had never
talked the president selected me as it
should be done it wasn't that we knew
each other it's not that we had a
long-standing relationship and I think
that's a testament to his selection
process
[Music]
well I think Cortez who kept Amazon out
of New York and they don't like her for
that thousands and thousands of jobs
I think Cortez is being very
disrespectful to somebody that's been
there a long time I deal with Nancy
Pelosi a lot and we go back and forth
and it's fine but I think that a group
of people is being very disrespectful to
her and you know what I don't think that
Nancy can let that go on a group of
people that came fried or know where
they came from I'm looking at this home
are from Minnesota and if one half of
the things they're saying about her are
true she shouldn't even be in office but
Cortez should treat Nancy Pelosi with
respect she should not be doing what
she's doing and I'll tell you something
about Nancy Pelosi that you know better
than I do she is not a racist okay she
is not a racist for them to call her a
racist is a disgrace
yeah very importantly today in a few
hours
vice president pence and the head of
Homeland Security are taking the press
and congresspeople into detention
centers and we're the ones that said
they were crowded they are crowded
because we have a lot of people but
they're in good shape and the reason is
because the fake news New York Times
wrote phony stories what Border Patrol
is doing they've become nurses and
janitors and doctors and they're not
trained for that what they've done is so
incredible so they're touring detention
centers and that was my idea
because I read a phony story in The New
York Times today for the other day about
the detention centers about the
conditions and I had people calling me
up at the highest levels from border
patrol and ice almost crying about that
phony story and they never saw anything
they have phony sources they don't even
have sources they write whatever they
want the New York Times is a very
dishonest newspaper they write what they
want and what they do is a tremendous
disservice to this country they are
truly the enemy of the people I'll tell
you that they are the enemy of the
people and what they wrote about
detention centers
is unfair now I believe it's going to be
the center they wrote about but we're
taking a tour there I'd love to be there
but I'm going to Ohio Wisconsin I'll be
going copy that but I've seen it I've
seen it and these centers are I mean to
have Ocasio say that drinking out of
toilets she made that up okay that's a
phony story she made it up and these
people they I'll tell you what I've been
with ice and I've been with Border
Patrol a lot they love those people
coming across the border they love them
and I've seen it they love them
[Applause]
so one of the reasons that Democrats
don't want to have a census is because
the number of people in the United
States for many years you know for years
you've heard 11 million it's far greater
than that but we'll find out because I'm
going to do something much more accurate
than the way we the way we did it in the
census would never have been very
accurate what we're doing will be much
more accurate the wall is being built
the wall is being built we had a couple
of very good decisions we had one bad
decision it's very tough again Paul Ryan
let us down Paul Ryan was a terrible
speaker frankly he was a baby he didn't
know what the hell he was doing the wall
let us down now in all fairness the
problem with during when we had both
houses in the Senate you need 60 votes
well we don't have 60 votes we have 50
won last time now we have 53 because we
won during the 18 election which nobody
wants to say just so you understand so
the wall is being built we had one
setback we had one tremendous victory
and I had a tremendous victory that was
very rarely covered by the press two
days ago
I won the emoluments case that was the
biggest case of them all I won the amali
of its case people don't know that by
being president I lose billions of
dollars by my being friends and
especially in money I can't make because
I don't do deals but I lose billions of
dollars but another thing I get a salary
of 400 or 450 thousand dollars a year I
don't think any other presidents ever
given up a lot of money almost a half a
million dollars I give it up I don't
think I've ever seen anybody saying I
give up my salary
I'm not looking for credit but I give up
my salary I get 0 I get 0 but you know
what makes me happy that we're doing a
great job and I want to thank Alex oh
gosh
he was a great great secretary
Iran better be careful but they're
treading on very dangerous territory
Iran if you're listening you better be
careful
[Applause]
[Music]
a big one yesterday we have some very
big cases having to do with that we'll
see where